we want to get the latest from dr tom
inglesby director of the center for
health security
at johns hopkins university doctor i
want to start with some more numbers put
them up on the screen more than 83
000 people are now hospitalized in this
country that's a record high
over 16 000 are in icus and more than
5 000 are on ventilators
why are we seeing this new spike
right now and how close are we to
overwhelming
our health care system
yeah well good morning chris thanks for
having me on your show uh
we are seeing this new spike because
uh of the gradual accumulation of
choices and policies over the last
couple of months this virus
has the ability to spread exponentially
meaning
more and more rapidly if we let it and
unlike the springtime when the country
really
was acting kind of in with common
purpose
around march and april at the start of
this pandemic and where that
the virus was located in in
comparatively fewer
places the epidemic now is surging
in almost every state in the country
with the midwest and the mountain west
really being
out really in front in terms of rapidly
accelerating numbers of cases
so it's not it's not confined to a few
places it's really
spread across the country it's not just
in big cities but it's in rural
locations
small towns and so that is adding up to
record numbers of hospitalizations and
as you said
uh the pressure on hospitals is the
highest it's been
since the beginning of the pandemic with
about a thousand hospitals reporting
this week that they are critically short
on healthcare workers or will be very
soon and that number will grow this week
so it's a very very serious moment for
the country in terms of this pandemic
at least 37 states are now
requiring people to wear mass in public
but the debate
over masks and partial or total closures
shutdowns is continuing here is south
dakota governor christie known
i'm not in favor of mandating mask
wearing i don't believe
that i have the authority to mandate
that and that people can use their own
personal responsibility to make a
decision when it comes to masks
what about the argument that government
can recommend
but it shouldn't be ordering people what
to do or not to do
well we trust government to do things to
keep us safe
so we trust government to set speed
limits in neighborhoods so we don't
drive too fast and risk you know
injuring or killing
kids who are playing in the street and a
neighborhood so i think
that would be the analogy i would think
of here i think there are some times
when it's really important for
government to set the rules
and to ask people to follow them and i
think this is one of those times
if 37 states can set mass mandates then
the rest of the states can set mass
mandates as well and they should
let me ask you about another aspect of
this particular debate new york city
just shut down its public schools school
system
forcing more than one million students
to stay at home but there
is some growing evidence that in fact
schools are not major spreaders of the
disease
here is cdc director dr robert redfield
this week
the truth is for kids k through 12 one
of the safest place they can be
from our perspective is to remain in
school
doctor what's the science are kids safer
staying in school
so it does look like at the k-8
level of school that kids are both at
certainly at lower risk of serious
disease
and probably because of the way school
happens
smaller groups of kids not mixing
together no large assemblies
that they are safer than high schools
or universities for example we haven't
had
reports of major outbreaks driving
transmission in communities
but on the other hand we are not
systematically enough collecting data
around the country right now
and schools that that have
made mitigation measures have been able
to decrease classroom density
have been able to make have kids wear
masks
end assemblies change pick up and drop
off
those schools we think are doing better
and are creating safer environments
but not all schools have been able to do
that not all schools have had the
resources to put mitigation measures in
place
so i do think it's hard to have
universal rules i i don't think we can
go that far but
in places where they put mitigation
procedures in place
and community transmission in that
particular school district
is relatively low i do think those are
safer environments
the problem is that now we are seeing
transmission levels across the country
that are higher than they've ever been
since the start of this pandemic so we
are kind of entering in
uncharted territory in many places which
have enormous
rates of spread so we haven't seen those
rates of spread in other parts of the
world so we don't really have those
places to learn from
and i think we have to be very cautious
about about making judgments about
safety in schools when the rate gets so
high in communities
and then there is thanksgiving we are
seeing already
airports with long lines of people
waiting online going through security
getting on planes should people travel
for thanksgiving or not and if they're
bound to anyway
what can they do to minimize their risk
so i would recommend that people do not
travel
on thanksgiving for this particular
holiday i think if you look at the map
of spread across the country you can see
the risk it's very visible
and moving through airports
or travel hubs i think that
will increase people's risk but even if
they're driving from point to point
unfortunately we don't know if we're
infected when we walk into a gathering
cdc came out with data this week that
said that
more than 50 percent of infections that
are happening are caused by people with
no
symptoms so i think the message for
everyone is
you can't assume that you don't have the
virus and you can't assume that the
people
whose home you're about to enter don't
have the virus at this point in our
pandemic
and so we really should discourage
traveling and kind of stick with our
nuclear families the people that we live
with
if you are going to travel to someone
else's home for thanksgiving
then if possible you should spend as
much time
outdoors when you're together in some
places that may be possible
with the weather other places not people
should be wearing masks and doors when
they're together
and only removing them when they're
eating we should probably keep
meals short and spend more time with
masks on
and the smaller the gatherings the
better but in general i would recommend
against it i love
being with my family on thanksgiving but
this year we're staying home just our
nuclear family
but dr scott atlas who is one of
president trump's top
coveted 19 officials gave very
different advice this week take a look
this kind of isolation is one of the
unspoken tragedies of the elderly
who are now being told don't see your
family at thanksgiving
for many people this is their final
thanksgiving believe it or not
what are we doing here
straight out should people listen to dr
atlas or not
yeah no i don't think so i think there
there are uh
a number of uh officials uh from the
from the us government who have 30 years
of experience
preparing for and responding to
infectious these disease outbreaks
including dr fauci uh
and i think their advice has been very
clear cdc's advice is very clear cdc's
job
is to try to prevent the spread of
outbreaks
i i think uh i don't know dr
atlas but his background is quite
different and
i think we should stick with the the
scientists who've led us through past
outbreaks
i got two questions i want to squeeze in
here so i'm going to need quick answers
from you first of all there is
some good news and that of course is the
fact that it looks like that we have not
one but two
vaccines as part of operation warp speed
that are on the way
pfizer on friday uh applied for
emergency youth authorization
assuming that they're approved by the
fda how confident
should americans be about taking these
vaccines
yeah i wouldn't call this good news i
would call this great news it's
fantastic it's probably the best news
we've had since the start of the
pandemic
we have two vaccines that are making
their way through the approval process
that
may be as high as 95 effective
and seem to be safe based on the
information we've seen so far
obviously they need to go through the
usual fda
review process and that's going to begin
now for one of the vaccines and we'll
begin shortly for the second
but if it does get through that process
and if they are reviewed by an external
scientific committee which has
no stake in the outcome except for the
safety and effectiveness for americans
of these vaccines
then i will have confidence in those
vaccines of course i want to know about
others
from within the government what they
think about it what dr falchi thinks
about it what other scientific
authorities
in fda and cdc think about it but at
this point i will have confidence
in the vaccine and if if it makes it
through those
processes and i'm i think it will help
us change the course of this pandemic in
the months ahead
finally and i need a quick answer here
the delayed
transition president-elect biden said
today that people may die
because the trump administration is not
reading them in
on vaccine distribution issues for a
seamless
turnover on january 20th but the
president's
press secretary kayleigh mcinerney that
information
is already out there take a look we
don't have access to all the information
that we need to get from all the various
agencies it's the kobit 19 vaccination
program the interim playbook for
jurisdiction operations
this is publicly available if the former
vice president would like to read
through it
is mcani right is the public playbook
enough no
it's not i mean there's so much going on
inside the government to prepare
to to respond to this pandemic and to
prepare for it i think about it like
a hospital taking care of many patients
when a shift is leaving
the doctors and nurses who've been
taking care of all these sick patients
they spend time with the shift that is
coming in they want to explain the
details
what could go wrong who's been in
trouble
that's the same thing that should be
happening now we should be going over
the details that people who are leaving
are going to need to take need to spend
time with and explain in detail all the
science
and the data for people who are coming
in
dr engelsby thank you thanks again for
your time and we wish you a happy and
safe thanksgiving sir
thanks so much chris you too